[Music]
Ronnie we got some kind of fire we got
units headed out there now
[Applause]
oh no y-you came all the way up here we
won't survive
[Music]
quod police part two picks up right
where white plays part one left off the
idea of these kids in this family
dealing with their safety net being
taken from them Evelyn is now a single
parent newborn baby the bonds burnt down
the house is destroyed and she's out
there on her own and she has to protect
these children they are forced to go out
into the world and see how other people
lived so they literally leave the path
of safety and go into the unknown it's
harrowing it's terrifying but at the
core of it it's a very human story I
don't like him all the way up here
there's nothing left
she's just trying to keep everybody
alive and discovers that there's other
people out there and the world changes
in an instant we answered all those
questions that the audience was asked
about day one especially how did this
all start every step is much more
treacherous
it definitely ratchets up the tension
and you know they're not safe
[Music]